موزة مَوْزَةْ أنَا مَوْزَة
أَحْمِلُ لِلْصِحَةِ كَنْزًا
مُنْعِشَةٌ وشَهِيَّةْ
وبالألياف غنية
موزة مَوْزَةْ أنَا مَوْزَة
موزة
أَحْمِلُ لِلْصِحَةِ كَنْزًا
كَنْزًا
مُنْعِشَةٌ وشَهِيَّةْ
شَهِيَّةْ
وبالألياف غنية
موزة موزة  موزة أنَا مَوْزَة
هاي
هَيَا كُلْنِي أُعْطِيكَ الطَّاقَةْ  تَنْشَطْ تَلْعَبْ بِلِيَاقَةْ
بِلِيَاقَةْ
وسَأَجْعَلُ قَلْبَكَ أَقْوَى كَيْ تَتَمَتَّعُ بِرَشَاقَة
بِرَشَاقَة
موزة موزة  موزة أنَا مَوْزَة
هاي
أَنَا غَنِيَّةْ بِالسُعْرَاتْ *** أَحْوِي أَيْضًا فِيتَامِينَاتْ
فِيتَامِينَاتْ
فِيَّا مَعَادِنُ ومُغَذِّيَات ***  أَنْفَعُ بَيْنَ التَّمْرِينَاتْ
موزة مَوْزَةْ أنَا مَوْزَة
مَوْزَة
أَحْمِلُ لِلْصِحَةِ كَنْزًا
كَنْزًا
مُنْعِشَةٌ وشَهِيَّةْ
شَهِيَّةْ
وبالألياف غنية
أَنَا أَنْفَعُ جِدًّا لِلْهَضْمْ
فَالمَوْزُ لِلْمَعِدَةْ مُهِمْ
جدا مهم
لاَ تُكْثِرْ مِنْ أَكْلِي لاَ
وَاحِدَةٌ تَكْفِي بِالْيَوْمْ
موزة موزة  موزة أنَا مَوْزَة
هاي